such a pleasure to make your
acquaintance thank you for doing this uh
congratulations on a big milestone
birthday recently how did you celebrate
I was actually in the Bahamas in the
island of Eleuthera at the bottom called
Caper luthra and uh was surrounded by
family and friends and sunshine and
water and it was perfectly relaxing and
the best yeah do you got everything that
you wanted for your uh yeah time off and
good weather
um yeah that's you know at this age
I'm just in that zone where I'm just
happy to do what I love and um
you know be surrounded by healthy family
that is there to support and and love
and and you know have control somewhat
over what I want to do in terms of
projects and creativity yeah it's
constantly morphing um that's what life
is all about and I'm always like okay
what's next is this how you pictured
things would be at the stage
I don't even know whether I ever
I I didn't say at 60 I'm going to be
here sure
um I am happy that I'm still
um creating I still have a career that I
love and still excited about what's the
next thing because I I've done recording
I'm back in the studio recording again
I've done television and film I've done
Broadway I'm in the producer space now
so I'm actually creating and helping to
create Broadway shows and and television
um uh ideas and that's really uh unusual
for me because I get a chance to
actually make decisions that affect more
than myself and it's empowering but it's
also another Frontier that I'm just
delving into where does that come from
that desire to not just want to keep
going but to be able to say I'm going to
try something new I'm going to do this
this challenge
I think it has to be one of those innate
personality things because there's some
people are like I'm fine I'm
overtowering I just want to relax
um I like to relax on a few days or a
couple months but I always have the
desire to uh explore what's the next
adventure who am I going to meet where
am I going to go and and how are we
going to make
something new right and I guess that's
just the the fire in the belly so I
guess that begs the question when you're
on a vacation in the Bahamas and like
are you the one who's gonna be like you
know what everybody relaxes we're all
having my ties or are you saying okay
we're going on catamaran and then we're
gonna go like you're you're number two
I'm I'm okay we've got bikes in the
garage guys what time are we going uh
how long a bike ride are we gonna do are
you doing 45 minutes or two hours which
you know so because I like to be active
and uh well I still can which is
fantastic and
um and I just again it's that
um exploring the island exploring you
know new things that are are
undiscovered or repeating what was fun
yesterday let's do it again and let's
bring more people yeah I I heard you say
that now you're giving yourself more
grace than you ever had before like it's
a privilege to be at this at the space
in your life is there a space in your
life where you would have given yourself
more grace uh before you know I look
back and I'm fortunate to have four
children who are great and uh and
watching them go through life but then
getting a chance to reflect on where I
was at that particular time in my life
and we tend to be hard on ourselves when
we're young really hard on ourselves why
aren't I here at the moment where I
should be why did I make enough money
why aren't people respecting me the way
I need to be done and a lot of we beat
ourselves up as youths we're we're
really hard in terms of trying to
achieve something immediately yeah and
showing that that's our value in every
aspect of the interview that you've
touched what was the one that you got to
and you went
I cannot believe I'm here right now like
this is thick and that just gave you the
most butterflies in your stomach the
moment that you knew you were about to
do it
well there's been plenty of moments like
that uh but I think as a the first
celebrity moment was when I was invited
to the White House for the first time as
Miss America I was 20 years old it was
October 18 1983 and uh President Reagan
and and the first lady were greeting me
and I was wearing my my the Gown that I
had won uh the the evening gown
competition in and I remember standing
in the receiving line and Halston was
next to me Ginger Rogers was in front of
me Martha Graham was on the other side
of me and these are legends that I grew
up watching and uh and then you get to
meet the president and the first lady
and then you go into the ballroom and
you're sitting and having an amazing
dinner
um that was when it was kind of an out
of body experience and again that was 20
years old I looked back at myself and
said oh my God I had that opportunity so
young in my life
pick me up Carry Me Out of Here of
course my mother said make sure you get
the president's autograph like Mom are
you kidding he's like no get it on the
menu so I literally flipped over the
menu I said can I please have and I
Ronald Reagan gave me his autograph when
fans come up to you what's the most
common thing that they say to you about
something you've done do they sing their
your songs back to you do they talk
about how much they loved you in a
particular show like what do they say to
you uh it's it's a myriad of things I'm
always I'm always curious because when
like young kids come up to me I'll say
how do you know me and they go oh Hannah
Montana the Movie yeah you were Hannah's
you're an as PR agent yeah in the movie
I'm like okay that's 2008 okay got that
and then I have people that are my age
that uh have been been with me my whole
journey and say you'll always be my Miss
America and that's a whole nother whole
another attitude
um I've had people come up to me that
said oh you were in The Odyssey we
watched this we watch that in History
Class you were Calypso said oh you know
me from that then people say the first
time I went to Broadway I saw you and
kissing the Spider Woman it was amazing
so I'm always excited to say how do you
know me oh really that's interesting
that's awesome I'm telling you save the
best for last when that came on at a
school dance uh that was it it was over
grab someone grab somebody oh we do
something with easy Canada called
confessions it's gonna be like a little
bit of Rapid Fire questions okay okay oh
you're holding on tight okay here we go
um how often do you Google yourself
never no now don't I don't I don't care
yeah yeah I do
uh what's the toughest lesson you've
learned about love about love
that it's ever changing I mean I try my
romantic love yeah yeah that is Ever
Changing you know you want it to stay
that way forever and it never does so
just be go with the flow go with the
flow uh what's the secret to living a
youthful life
being excited about life and things and
doing things you know it's one thing to
say oh one of these days I'm gonna do it
but do it yeah do it get up and do it
make book that plane trip you know if
something's on your bucket list then do
it now do it
um I've heard you're a fan of Tim
Hortons
well we do have we have a couple here
right right of course we have them in
Buffalo but yes so go to order the 10
bits yeah we'll get a little bit then
the coffee is fantastic there you go
yeah and also there's sausage there's
sausage biscuit breakfast sandwich is
delish this has been brought to you by
Tim Hortons thank you very much
uh what's your guilty pleasure TV show
oh right now succession it's our um one
more episode that's so well written and
so well acted and the cinematography
when they take you to these amazing
places that you get a chance to kind of
just drop in uh it's spectacular yeah
when you watch something that you get so
engrossed in does that inspire you are
you like oh I gotta do something like
that well yeah the first thing is like
you to call your agency uh why aren't on
at the show and can't we get a role for
me in the show
um but then I'm inspired I'm inspired
um uh I have a friend who represents
Karen caulk and I was like tell him he
is killing it I just I watched uh the
last episode of the at the funeral and
he killed it and I was like why am I
crying and man he's so good yeah and I
just said just give him all my my love
he's killing it so those are the the
things that make you excited about
acting again like oh I can't wait to get
it work with this writer work with the
on Samba like that that is so inspiring